voici un enfant
bonsoir bonsoir ludivine sagnier donc et
la jeune actrice qui monte et qui
descend olivier olivier de kersauson
laurent baffie alors vous êtes ici pour
deux raisons alain chamfort la première
c'est que j'adore vos chansons que j'ai
envie de les faire écouter les faire
entendre à ceux qui ne connaissent pas
très bien alors on les trouve ses
chansons on les trouve sur un cd qui
s'appelle ce n'est que moi
1 2 3 tab à 6
quand on écoute ce disque on vérifie que
j'ai le même problème que que julien
clerc c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est un
grand mélodiste et j'ai bien clair on
parle toujours de ses paroliers on parle
de roda gil maurice vallet voilà on
parle rarement de la qualité de ses
mélodies alors qu'il a fait les mélodies
toutes ses chansons avoue c'est un peu
pareil
donc voilà je tiens à vous rendre
hommage
la deuxième raison de votre présence ici
ce soir c'est les concerts du 19 et du
20 février à la cité de la musique avec
bertrand burgalat et son as dragon avec
helena noguerra comme ici d'ailleurs la
semaine prochaine alors j'ai voulu et
bien parce que j'ai deux par bonds
détient un chanteur à minettes quoi on
peut dire un chanteur inséminateur et
puis vous êtes une carrière comme ça de
plus en plus personnelle de plus en plus
artiste on va en parler
ça vous connaissez cette chanson de la
compagnie alain barrière ouais j'ai un
panier j'ai joué pendant un peu plus
d'un an de galère bon je peux pas dire
ça non c'est à dire que la sociaux c'est
que ça m'a fait prendre conscience qu'il
fallait que je fasse autre chose que de
rester musicien accompagnateur ce que je
partais avec une équipe qui était à peu
près j'ai tous depuis vingt ans de plus
que moi mais quand je voyais ces garçons
on partait dans la camionnette avec les
costumes un peu élimé tout ça je disais
c'est pas d'avenir que j'ai envie
d'avoir alors détenant 49 fautes vrai
nom c'est alain le govic votre père
était chef de service chez thomson
s'impliquer et votre mère tenait un
magasin de vêtements voilà alors si
votre marraine qui était prof de piano
qui vous a poussé vers le piano un peu
comme delphine a poussé ludivine vers la
comédie
c'est ce et s'assure repéré que j'avais
là une bonne oreille et donc elle a
incité mes parents à mettre au piano
c'est ça alors une première note voulait
jouer sur le piano droit familial dans
un petit deux pièces sur cour
c'est un peu causette à un petit deux
pièces sur un lourd boulevard
victor-hugo à clichy oui alors à clichy
toute la famille et des problèmes
respiratoires plus surtout moi les
webmasters jeu et vous partez en en bien
oui bon exact mois là et vous apprenez
le piano avec l'amicale vous dites moi
comment tu sais que ce sera inamical
coup la semaine dernière j'ai tellement
foutus de ma gueule avec sac maintenant
plus personne n'ose le dire
alors donc vous avez beaucoup d'oreilles
effectivement si on aperçoit à ce moment
là beaucoup de facilités pour la musique
qui vous fait des concours salle gaveau
avoue commencer comme ça voyez la scala
quant aux roms
qu'on ai réunis c'est parti pour être un
musicien classique un pianiste gentil
lorsqu'arrive salut les copains de
daniel filipacchi et franck ténot et là
bon sa vie en même temps que l'éveil de
la siagi l'adolescence tout ça donc ça
vous bouleverse terriblement donc même
si je n'avais pas de grandes capacités
de danseurs j'étais un de ceux qui
entraient dans le jeu 11è des fêtes de
fin d'année de classe et tout ça et
j'étais je viens danser je suis le
cha-cha-cha les twins n'est pas tout ces
trucs de négoce est arrivé vous êtes et
106 de la seule viviez-vous quoi le rock
les noms j'écoute chez quoi vous des
cornemuses
non je ne la musique jamais aimé la
musique jamais mis un indice de ma vie
donc sa maman vous écoutez quoi sur
votre bateau alors là j'ai la mer la mer
match est alors à l'époque vous créez
vos premiers groupes qui avaient des
noms vraiment les dreamer c'est shaker
et muratore les mods une joue au golf
drouot annonce la grande époque du bon
goût de la locomotive et des concours à
cette époque-là cm et les concours et
j'ai commencé j'ai fait des concours
avec elle n'apparaissait jonas aussi
qu'ils étaient dans le king 7les ouais
donc on était des gens seuls
c'est connu cette époque là très
influencé par londres vous êtes dans un
trip un peu anti rockeur très élégant
avec les petits costumes cintrés les col
roulé sous les chemises les parapluies
ce qu'on appelait les modes à l'époque
alors là vous rencontrer et jacques
dutronc un qui était lui habillé par
carven et se sépare car ville et vous
devenez voilà vous devenez un musicien
nous jouer sur tous les disques dutronc
les playboys jouer ouais j'aime méfiez
vous jouez et à 18 ans et pendant un an
et demi vous devenez un musicien donc
accompagnateurs de dutronc vous faites
partie de la bande et c'est un peu comme
une secte quoi sert que dutronc il a
toujours eu lieu autour de lui comme ça
des copains très proche
oui c'est à dire c'est dès le départ et
nous nous emmène partout avec lui
c'est un peu de promo de la radio de la
télé de la presse et on arrivait à 12
et puis et puis laisser circuler entre
nous quoi se dire qu'il a toujours
beaucoup utilisé son environnement
proche qui les aident dans lequel ils se
sentent en sécurité qu'il aimait bien
pour ça lui permettait d'être
d'être à l'aise soit tout simplement
aujourd'hui ça continue parce qu'il ya
cette bande de corse ont tout quitté
pour lui et qui traitent des fois un peu
dur et renouveler les équipes
ouais toujours conservé cette méthode
comportement chef de secte un peu bourré
alors c'est dutronc en fait qui vous
initie à la vie de star les relais
châteaux la braguette tout ça quoi oui
ben j'avais 17 ans quoi tant que comme
je quittais mes parents et que j'avais
une vie relativement sans histoire
agirait les ailes d'un seul coup de
partir en tournée avec avait dans un
plein succès en plus lui est en pleine
bourre à ce moment-là ça marchait
vraiment très fort l'argent les
premières filles enfin tout ça c'était
assez amusant pas le dépuceler cema
initiés mais alors malgré le soutien de
françoise hardy
il ya de l'eau dans le gaz entre dutronc
et vous d'abord les filles parce que
comme il était un petit peu intimidés
par la star je vais plutôt vers vous
pour que vers moi on était cinq
musiciens j'ai plus que rapide quoi ils
vous diraient pourquoi alors parce qu'il
a appris que vous préparez un disque de
votre côté oui c'est ça j'avais un
projet faire un 45 tours sont été
proposée par dick rivers à l'époque
et quand jacques la prime est un peu
énervé je crois non ouais ouais on la
commence la galère en plein mai 68 vous
retrouver sans boulot avoue jouer car
vers léonard ait charden ça c'est dur
avec alain barrière charden avance
thomas et monty qui se souvient encore
de mer
aujourd'hui on s'est un peu la galère et
puis un jour vine buggy vous présente
claude françois deuxième grande
rencontre de votre vie après après
jacques dutronc et c'est que nous ce
qu'on soit kivu baptise chamfort et non
plus le govic chamfort écrivain français
c'est le service public
jean faure écrivain français du xviiie
siècle qui s'appelait pas vraiment
champagne lui non plus d'ailleurs donc
il s'appelait rock nicolas pourquoi
finalement alors tout buteront c'était
un peu l'anti star avec l'autre en soit
vous découvrez la vraie star oui c'est à
dire dutronc c'était le détachement
c'était une manière de deux d'esquiver
les choses tout temps de ne jamais là où
on l'attendait de ne pas vouloir entrer
dans les conventions du métier et puis
claude françois c'était peut-être
totalement l'opposé à quelqu'un qui est
appliquée notamment d
espèce de raie de recettes le mot est
pas gentil mais qui étaient de vrais
mon application d'un système de
marketing alors au début vous êtes
engagés dans le staff de flèches de
disques flèche de pouls de françois pour
écrire des chansons
mais en fait il ne chantait pas vraiment
et un jour il vous livre des pièces que
tu les chante finalement ses chansons
parce que tu allais noter une bonne voie
serait peut-être plus que ce soit toi
qui les chante
il vous dit je m étais poster dans
podium la note était prévu était
convaincant et là où fait les premières
parties de tout françois lors les
cheveux les cheveux mi-longs costume
vert pomme je ne citerons séducteur
comme ça un peu précieux un peu efféminé
très minée couasnon chanteur à minettes
gens des variétés maroc est le principal
public à qui on s'adressait autant les
jeunes filles et bientôt vous avez avec
tout françois le même problème qu'avec
dutronc si tu es jaloux et méchant nazi
est mort on s'en fout un peu
c'est vrai nom s'était il était dans la
compétition et notamment il a vécu il
avait acheté un besoin de convaincre de
plaire d'être toujours numéro 1 re étape
jeunes vous vous énervez pas jaloux mais
ça l'énervé cocheren d'en bas des
disques flèche et vers certaines filles
des qui normalement étaient rassemblés
pour lui et gagner sortait elle
commençait à me regarder un point donc
ça l'énervé évidemment si vous n'êtes
pas tellement aidé d'avoir été beaux
mecs parce que vous êtes informés et
puis sur scène aussi faisait des coups
durs par exemple faisait la première
partie de ses concerts
alors vous aviez 50% de la sono 50 % de
la lumière 50% des musiciens est quant à
lui arrivé pour la deuxième partie il
avait 100% de tout ça oui elle rétablit
pas mais c'est pas très sympa certain
moment où il m'a fait les coûts qui
était pas très sympa c'est vrai alors là
vous décidez de vous organisez vous même
et vous partez que gérard louvin oui sur
la route quand ça veut pas sourire oui
on a travaillé en une dizaine d'années
une dizaine d'années ensemble voilà il
avoue fait la troisième rencontre
importante de votre vie serge gainsbourg
toujours par les femmes c'est jane qui
vous à jane birkin qui vous a un peu
branché sur le coup c'est vrai qu'elle a
expliqué un peu à serge qui j'étais et
je pense qu'elle a réussi à le
convaincre travail moi qu'au départ ils
savaient pas trop de sûreté en scène
j'ai été déçu aussi parce qu'au départ
faillite est comme ça c'est à dire qu'il
vous raconte votre vie le premier soir
elle boit un couple ils pensaient que
vous êtes son meilleur ami
et puis vous rendez compte que le
lendemain raconte exactement la même
chose à un flic quoi oui c'est sûr déçu
c'est un peu décevant mais bon c'est la
règle et j'en finirai quoi et c'est vrai
qu'on sentait un peu confident donc on
disait bon on est dans une position un
peu particulier il est joli et papiers
puis c'est un numéro qui vient un peu
mou s'est régulièrement qu'on s'est un
peu oui oui dans le show-business votre
histoire alors deuxième problème avec
gainsbourg c'est qu'ils n'étaient pas
très bosseur
parce qu'après aux armes et caetera vous
l'avez écrit des tubes comme ça en cinq
minutes sur des coins de table
il pensait qu'il pouvait le faire tout
le temps donc vous vous étiez au
contraire un type très très appliqué
très scrupuleux très méticuleux présente
quand vous lui apportez la musique de
manureva qui est musique tous les quatre
et tubesque lui fait 105 me qui vous
fait à dieu california oui il est déjà
lyautey à lui fournir fait vraiment bon
ce n'est pas le montre avec quoi mais là
- la force de je n'ai pas lâché n'est
pas le schéma est un jour il fait un
dîner on lui parle de colas d'un col à
l'amant de la cola et le sens il deviner
il écrit manuel valls vous appelle pour
vous dire voilà écoute ça coco et puis
voilà dutronc cloclo gainsbourg et puis
un jour vous devenez alain chamfort